الحرب لا تدور فقط في ساحات المعارك بل ان
جزءا كبيرا منها يظهر في الكواليس فيرتكز
بالاساس على العاملين النفسي والاستراتيجي
وليس الحربي فقط والحال لا يختلف في الحرب
الاوكرانيه فما هي الحيل التي يستخدمها كل
طرف في هذه الحرب الموازيه صحيفه تانج
البريطانيه سلطت الضوء على ما وصفته
المعركه النفسيه والاستراتيجيه بين روسيا
واوكرانيا فبالنسبه لروسيا تقول الصحيفه
ان التهديد باستخدام السلاح النووي كان
المناوره السياسيه الاكثر وضوحا وتقول
الصحيفه ان بوتين يرغب فقط في اثاره قلق
المعسكر الغربي لدفعهم الى الضغط على كييف
من اجل فتح مفاوضات للسلام ومن بين الحيل
النفسيه التي تستخدمها موسكو ايضا تقول
الصحيفه هي عمليه التجنيد وهي خطه ترمي
الى اخافه اوكرانيا وحلفائها فقط وليس
بسبب وجود حاجه حقيقيه
وكما هو الحل بالنسبه لموسكو فان الوضع لا
يختلف بالنسبه لكياف التي استعملت الكثير
من الخدع النفسيه والاستراتيجيه منذ بدايه
الحرب وتقول الصحيفه ان اوكرانيا تقوم
بشكل دوري بتعديل قواتها خلف خط المواجهه
لمنع موسكو من الحصول على تفاصيل دقيقه عن
خطاطها كما ان اوكرانيا تعمد الى تشتيك
القوات الروسيه من خلال نشر معلومات
مغلوطه حول نيتها استهداف منطقه محدده
وذلك من اجل جذب الجنود الروسي لتقوم
بعدها باستهداف منطقه اخرى كما حدث قبلا
في خاركس